hey what's up guys it's Mary here at e3
2016 and I am here with Andria's Suika
from daedalic entertainment how's it
going great show so far yeah it's been a
really good III and you guys are in for
a treat right now because we're about to
show you the long journey home which is
actually you know it's we can summarize
it as a space exploration RPG but
there's a lot more to it isn't there
yeah actually it's highly inspired by
Star contro 2 which was already a game
hard to explain in our game you choose 4
out of 10 characters and you make the
first light jump of mankind it goes
wrong and you try to figure out your way
home through procedurally generated
universe and there you meet really
strange aliens and you try to make
friends alright so let's just jump right
into it right now and we in explain
exactly what you're even doing to get
into the game itself okay so at the
beginning you can choose between
different ships like that and you can
choose between Al and different lenders
because you can land on all planets and
then you choose character so I'm I do
that quite quick here because I go into
it when we when we do move the game so I
just choose four of them so the first
thing I personally think is really neat
is you can enter a code here and that
generates a galaxy so you can tell the
code to a friend so we can do that game
that way you guys can actually be in the
same world because it's actually
generating a unique world for you yeah
but it's a single-player game so it's
really like you just can't tell your
friend and then you can play the step is
the same thing because it's picking all
the alien races and all the procedures
generated stuff is picked out of the
seat yeah so you can try to play the
same again with different crew or you
can tell your friend where you got stuck
and he can try yeah that's the basic
idea that's amazing and now how many
seeds can be generated oh actually it's
up to you you just give enter the code
that's I cannot really tell how much
that is so it really depends a little
bit on on what's picked so now you did
mention that this was a rogue like and
that's also shown by the procedural
generation what else makes this more of
a roguelike so what's really important
for us that you make I think a good game
is about making interesting decisions I
was doing strategy games for several
years at Ubisoft and if you make a game
about decisions it has to matter so
pick that you have not you do not you
make a choice and you cannot go back and
and say oh I didn't like the outcomes
the consequences so we have this kind of
permadeath and only one safe game thing
and once you die what happens to the
seed oh you can start again with the
same seed and then try again but was
maybe us as a crew but in now it is
perma death so you lose everything you
lose everything for that run yeah no
tell me more I find it really
fascinating Andre us that you actually
have 15 years EB soft you were creative
director of some pretty big game yeah it
was setlist it's quite big and I know a
big brands in Germany not so when on
outside of Germany's or city building
games yeah and I was there were bigger
teams and now we are only 8 people and
some of them came with me from you soft
and yeah now we're doing that you pulled
some crew to make a small ragtag team of
developers working on this game then
yeah and some externals like we have a
really good audio composer it's Kai
Rosenkranz he was doing a music for
Gothic which is also a nice RPG and yeah
so we we are only 8 people or we have
Richard covered he is he's our writers
from the UK but beside that we we are
small team so angel plaster so tell me
what's going on right now what are you
doing right now in the world so from the
story point of view we are already at
the other side of the galaxy and this is
a procedure generated procedure
generated planet and our event systems
taking care that interesting stuff is
happening so here for example is a ruin
and I just find an ancient carving here
I can take it but that's already a
decision because if I take a relict for
a race that's I'm flying around with it
and meet that race that might really
hate that but I take it anyway for the
presentation so I would currently I
going up to this to space to the orbit
and talk on my big ship to see to show
you what we can do with the relics
so I've seen in some of the descriptions
that you guys have had a lot of
inspirations both from games but also
stories or shows I've seen that Firefly
as an inspiration to you how how are
those types of things like Firefly how
do you see that in this game so
fireflies Kili was a crew but it's
Farscape was really a strong influence
not many people know that anymore
because about it was a very very good TV
show with really strange aliens we are
more in this universe of Fifth Element
guardians of the galaxy yes I was a
little bit more nitty-gritty kind of
universe yeah that's it
so here's your crew right now and you
can actually see their health meters so
what are you doing in this area so
currently here that's really the heart
of the game so I for this run I picked
for example Nikolaj he is he's a Russian
researcher he is one of the guys who
invented the jump drive that's the
reason why everybody is complaining at
the beginning when you pick him or we
have kiss and she was on the ISS - she's
astronaut but what they give you is
really everything you find in the game
you can show them in the laboratory like
here and if I pick for example if I
would have picked an engineer he would
be able to do something with this device
one of the easiest ones is like I have a
Badgett bed appendages sorry English not
my native plant and I can use it to heal
Benoit but as I have for example Nikolay
as a researcher and I found an ancient
carving I can ask him to analyze things
but just a complainer in the doing this
we never found something I don't know
why it happened like that it depends on
the seat we entered so maybe GameSpot is
a better seat than the seats I used
today it seems like it is it is actually
he found something so now I can take a
look in the database and here I have a
new quest running so to breed a quest
lost temple in the sector it's on a rock
planet and all our stories we are
writing I really like Chinese stories
and the system is stitching them
together so they are branching a lot
depending on my decisions yeah so now we
are in space I think one other thing
that's really important for us is we
wanted to make flying around in space
more interesting and actually we are a
little bit space nerds and
the colleague I have found it's a
company versus doctor in biology so we I
really like we love simulating kind of
things and in the real world there is a
real challenge and what you see here is
a trajectory of officer of the of our
spaceship and currently the Sun is
pulling me and so we have real Anna teri
gravity's and I can use it to my
advantage so yeah
I currently try to go to the next planet
and if I turn around my ship and D
accelerate and the planetary gravity is
putting me in and I can do a slingshot
so it's amazing that you're using
physics that you would find more
realistic or practical in your game
where you're actually using
gravitational pull and thrusters to kind
of get to your actual destination is
there danger in this can you actually
like die in this area right here so what
can happen is if I if I don't maneuver
right then the who is actually taking
over like that and and that damaged the
ship a little bit so it's what we don't
have in common with other relax as we
are not so unforgiving we won't really
to player to experience a story and his
own story so we do not have this random
like I know you're a dad I kind of thing
but yeah if you go to a black hole for
example maybe I hope you can see that in
the video but there's a gravity well
it's a grid so you can see when for
example here's a Sun is pulling me in
and if you have a if you have a big
black hole or I shouldn't go too close
to the Sun that's not good for the
shipment sounds like it's giving you a
lot of warnings as well there's a lot of
visual warnings to let you know and you
you're getting yourself into some
trouble yeah we wanted to make the
interface as slick as possible so we try
to put all the feedback on the science
as much in the game as possible let's do
a jump because I really want to show
where we are at the other side of the
galaxy so now I make it jump that looks
really good actually by the way also
that animation thank you
so here we are in a nebula and by the
way funny story is a nebulous we are
generating out of Hubble telescope
pictures we are here we can jump around
in this nebula it's a real bubble go yes
I really have a tesco picture we use a
lot of that for example for MA we also
use High Definition mass and moon
textures to mix into our planets it's
common sauce you can use it
and actually is much more beautiful than
doing it by hand so it seems like I
wonder if you like have any like actual
images like from like NASA and anything
else helping you along your way to make
this game yeah that's really we have
also some sounds they have a sound
library or allowed to use so we a little
bit like like the sky no space notes see
by the way is service we have to go
there so this is a galaxies and all that
has been generated so the only two fixed
points the end of the galaxy and the
solar system and now I'm going there we
have to make the jumps but if you want
to go to the next nebula we have to go
through this big gates here and the
gates are occupied by aliens and so I
have to make friends to go there so I
make a jump in the direction I hope that
we can show the gate because if you like
that animation I'm pretty sure you like
the other one much more now I mean this
kind of seems like a silly questions
that I have to ask like what prevents
you from just jumping the whole way I
mean you have to be prevented from just
getting there that's right and we have
the jump drive has only a certain range
maybe you saw that in the video there
was a circle around that I can only jump
within that range and that depends a
little bit on which ship I have chosen
and then to go to the next to the next
nebula I have to use the gates and I'm
not it's not easy to use the gates
because they are occupied by by aliens
okay and so now how are you getting
around that are you talking to these
people and trying to figure it out do
you need more resources so actually I
try to do favors so I have two for
example here as there was and there was
a distress beacon I just oh [ __ ]
oh my god yeah that's why we talked and
didn't took a look at the screen so what
happened here is this little guy needed
help and actually he needed to have her
and he hailed me and I didn't answer
because I was not taking playing it
alien dead now this little alien is dead
and that would not raise my reputation
so I think my reputation went down now
so if they have a part of the if they
have the gate belongs to them they will
be maybe pissed and not let me through
so that's that was a bad thing actually
we should have taken a look at that yeah
so yeah so I find another little alien
and help someone else okay here's
another one but is it sir is a slavery
race I can spoil that so they are not
the nicest people in the world but I'm
still gonna help them because you need
to raise your rap can you choose not to
you can choose whatever you want that's
idea of the game that you have you're
really free and doing stuff like we I
just intercepted this one there's a big
ship I should not let's call him maybe
we keep talking with me okay so this is
our dialogue system we wanted to have
this kind of when I started the game I
wanted to have this feeling of cultural
clash of cultures like in Italian guy
tries to talk with a Japanese guy and it
goes completely wrong we wanted to have
that in the game so we don't have
multiple-choice dialogue system we were
a little bit old-school kind of you
gathering words so for example we have
this ancient carving and I can ask him
about Asian carving but as you see he's
actually an arrogant prick
wait what did he say what about this
face makes you think you would care
about that he's a he's given you some
[ __ ] right now
yes so I can ask about gossip so maybe
he's telling me something about this
area as part of the galaxy or I can talk
about himself but it can go wrong so if
I talk for example about home it could
mean he could understand I want to talk
about my home or his home so there's
always some misconception I could do you
basically get snippets of dialogue that
you can make the assumption of what it
means but the actual character can make
the wrong assumption and and this could
also result in really interesting things
like maybe he gets offended by something
that you didn't think you were trying to
be offensive
I checked exactly we have four examples
as one race in the game that's easy to
be discussed and if you show them stuff
so I don't like sighs I oh my god you
cannot show that and stop communication
with you so that's
that's actually the part of the game you
have to figure out how the cultures are
and who's I how they react it's really
fascinating to see that that's like kind
of also a true issue with mixing culture
is that you don't know when something is
inappropriate or not and you take those
risks when you talk to these people when
we when we talk where we often we get
the question what do you take for the
next run so actually we do not unlock
stuff so most of the time you unlock
knowledge so next time you play the game
and you have the same alien race you
have learned already a little bit how
you have to treat with them I just
reared iving into this planet
there's no sense actually there was a
city of the elites I but I do not want
to talk with them here let's see let's
go to a gate I think sometimes really
flowing way let's see if we can make it
to a gate before this I love how you
have multiple different types of
gameplay mechanics from floating around
in space and trying to make it to the
next point but then you also have the
planets side where you're actually
maneuvering the ship in a 2d fear and
then you have communication screens so
it looks like there's a lot to this game
but when you break it down it's pretty
easy to ingest there's it's like not too
overwhelming here Thanks um yeah I we
tried that for example the gameplay is
always 2d because we were not eager to
have this kind of 3d navigating kind of
thing we wanted to have really about the
story about the characters to have years
again the same so I'm going to engage
now already
um jail for that son yeah I should not
go over that
the crew is currently talking about it
so we just met so they get more and more
dialogue depending on who I met what
I've done so they give me either hints
what to do next
they get angry do they get hungry they
don't get hungry so only we have fuel
that's already enough to take care of so
we not know no oxygen or something like
that so we say that the SIP is providing
that we do not want to go to that level
of stimulation yeah it seems pretty
exhausting to take care of everyone so
you're kind of like letting them take
care of themselves but they do have
health meters yeah they can get they can
get parasites or program arms or so ever
and then I have to take care for them we
can take a look in the quarter so for
example this knezovich splash so I can
try but to figure out I can docked on a
star port but unfortunately the stop or
don't have a shop I could but maybe buy
stuffs there to here if I would have a
doctor you might be able to do something
out of a plant I can find on the surface
a little bit of Oregon Trail vibes going
on here because you're traveling and
trying to make sure everyone survives
but you can't do everything sometimes
people are going to be sick and there's
gonna the deal that's it so last week we
had we had a quite of interesting place
for someone we're playing the game and
he reaches was one guy left and he had
broken ribs and parasites all other
three characters died and he was friend
was roast enemy aliens in the universe
and he was sitting there seeing the
president saying I'm not sure if it was
worth it
so I really like that because actually
he brought one guy home but he made a
whole mess to the whole universe and the
human mankind was at the end friend was
yeah was it's our slave arrays as I said
it's a really dark ending and
I have a positive one if you if you are
not true if you for example that yeah
that's okay we just paid some money here
but that can be bigger stories around
again but here that one we were lucky
that one you just wanted some money to
transport us to the next to the next
part so yeah actually there are a lot of
moral choices in the game so you can
meet a race that's attacking you that's
much stronger and I offering you two to
let you go if you give one of your guys
to the zoo he is doing so you have to
choose one crew member who's going into
the alien zoo you're sacrificing your
own members actually they are that
depends on the characters you have if
they respond like yeah I'm okay I'm
doing it for the team or if I say like
no don't let me go but it's
heartbreaking yeah it is we want that
you really feel something about the crew
and you to feel something about the
aliens and that's the reason why we put
so much effort on that stuff how long it
does it play through on average take to
get home if you're successful actually
we are currently experimenting a little
bit but it's between four and six hours
and we can easily make the galaxy much
bigger because it's procedure generated
or we can take who's that longer at what
that was a good look that's it
they're called look because they makes
us little luke noises exactly and so
it's around four and six hours and which
rank thanks we want to have a good flow
of events that are happening so we
either it makes the galaxy bigger or
smaller I put more stories in it because
in not all aliens and stories are in
each run so when you generate the code
and starts a galaxy it can it's only
some of them are picked but it's up to
the player and the whole point of this
is replayability the idea that every
time you play this you have a completely
new experience
yeah and it's they're super hidden stuff
inside so you only get when you have a
certain character and then on a certain
planet and have a certain race in it and
make a certain decision and then you
find something so today I found
something I even didn't know that's in
the game because we made the little
pieces and then suddenly something
hadn't I was so excited that during
Zinta I was like oh wow what's that so I
was more into the games in the interview
age it's amazing that you can find
things that you've never even seen
before in your own game yeah I love that
I mean that's really special well thank
you so much for the demo where can
people learn more about it when can they
expect to find it and
and played themselves so we have already
a steam page running you can take a look
there we have a web page th game calm
and we have a facebook site Twitter and
PC and of the year next year PC Xbox one
and ps4 okay that's the long journey
home it sounds like this is going to be
coming out on console and PC very
shortly and do you have a price on that
yet I don't know it it's a mystery for
now but you guys can find out more about
that thanks a lot Andreas